NBC News says two of its former
journalists are outright lying that the
network tried to block an explosive
report about Harvey Weinstein
investigative producer rich McHugh says
NBC News displayed a massive breach of
journalistic integrity telling him and
Ronan Farrow to stand down on their
investigation of Weinstein's alleged
sexual misconduct
Jericka Duncan is following the
intensifying feud Jericka good morning
good morning McEwen Farrow spent eight
months gathering information on the
media mogul but NBC News says the story
wasn't ready for air because not a
single witness or victim of Weinstein's
alleged crimes would go on the record
well the company says when it told
Pharaoh that he took the report
elsewhere I walked into the door at The
New Yorker with a an explosively
reportable piece that should have been
public earlier in a New York Times
article published Thursday night ronan
pharaoh's former producer rich McHugh
said that during the final stages of
their report into Harvey Weinstein's
alleged sexual misconduct he and Pharaoh
felt resistance we were told to put the
story on the back burner McHugh also
claimed three days before they were
going to interview a woman with a
credible rape allegation against
Weinstein he was ordered to stand down
on the story altogether from the highest
levels of NBC and that Weinstein
allegedly called NBC executives directly
once he says while he was in the room
with them at a time when I had spent
months and months in rooms with
executives saying this is not a story
you know pack it up why won't you just
give up on this
in a statement to CBS News an NBC News
spokesperson says in part the assertion
that NBC News tried to kill the
Weinstein story while Ronan Farrow was
at NBC is an outright lie two months
after leaving NBC Farrow published his
piece on The New Yorker that included
several alleged victims by name
including hacia Argento Mira Sorvino and
Rosanna Arquette none of them were
included in the reporting he presented
at NBC News to have fellow reporters who
got close over the course of 20 years
almost say yeah no this is real we came
really close we wanted to get this and
we couldn't reach McHugh says he will
not disclose which executives had told
him to stand down
his reporting the president of NBC News
says Weinstein had no influence on the
network's handling of the Weinstein
story Weinstein denies all allegations
of sexual assault
Norah Jericka thank you